لفهم المخاوف الحقيقية من
صراع أوسع نطاقًا في الشرق الأوسط، من
المفيد إلقاء نظرة فاحصة على محور
المقاومة، وكلاء وحلفاء
إيران، الذي يمتد من البحر الأحمر إلى
البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​الآن، وقد
أشعلت حماس هذا التوتر الإقليمي الأخير.  الهجمات
على إسرائيل في 7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر) والحرب الإسرائيلية
اللاحقة في غزة، تقول الولايات المتحدة إن
حماس يتم تمويلها وتجهيزها وتدريبها في بعض الأحيان
من قبل إيران على الرغم من أن تان ادعى أنها
لم تكن متورطة في
هجوم 7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)، ثم أصبح وكلاء إيران الآخرون
متورطين في 8 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)، حزب الله في
لبنان واحد من  أقوى القوات
في المنطقة تضم حوالي 100.000
مقاتل ولها صلات
بالحكومة اللبنانية، أطلقت صواريخ عبر
الحدود على شمال إسرائيل، وهو ما
رد عليه الجيش الإسرائيلي الآن، مما
أثار لأول مرة مخاوف من نشوب
صراع أوسع نطاقًا بعد ذلك في 19 أكتوبر مع
المتمردين الحوثيين في  بدأ اليمن
بإطلاق الصواريخ أولاً ضد إسرائيل
ثم غيروا تركيزهم إلى استهداف
السفن التجارية في البحر الأحمر مما
تسبب في فوضى عالمية في
صناعة الشحن، ولم توقف الضربات الأمريكية والبريطانية ضد
أهداف في اليمن هذه
الهجمات المستمرة في العراق، وهناك
عدد من الهجمات الإيرانية  الميليشيات المدعومة
والتي تنشط بشكل متزايد منذ
الحرب في غزة وتستهدف القوات الأمريكية في
البلاد بشكل شبه يومي وتعمل
تحت مظلة مجموعة
المقاومة الإسلامية في العراق، توحدت في
الأيديولوجية لكنها مقسمة في
العمليات مما يجعلها أكثر صعوبة
في
استهدافها.  أخيرًا، سوريا، يُعتقد أن إيران
نشرت ما يصل إلى 80 ألف رجل لدعم
الزعيم بشار الأسد في
الحرب الأهلية السورية منذ عام 2011، ومن
غير الواضح كم عدد هؤلاء الرجال الذين بقوا
بعد 7 أكتوبر، كما تعرضت القوات الأمريكية أيضًا
لهجمات بطائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ
هنا.  في سوريا وكذلك مع إصابات
لبعض أفراد الخدمة الأمريكية، وعندما يتعلق الأمر
بكل هذه البلدان، فإن جميع الطرق تؤدي إلى
إيران التي شاركت بنفسها في هجمات في
العراق وسوريا هذا الأسبوع، بما في ذلك
أكبر عملية صاروخية وأكثرها تعقيدًا
وفقًا
لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية الإيرانية التي وصلت إلى البعض.  1200 كيلومتر أو أكثر
من 740 مليونًا تضع إسرائيل في
متناول يدها، ليس هناك الكثير مما يشير في هذه
المرحلة إلى أن إيران تريد بالفعل
صراعًا مباشرًا مع إسرائيل أو
الولايات المتحدة، لكن الوصول العددي الكبير
لوكلائها إلى الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها يثير حتماً المخاوف.
صراع أوسع غير مقصود لباولا
هانكوك على قناة سي إن إن أبو
ظبي